[Music]
[Music]
cerro blanco is the biggest sand dune in
the world i had no idea people could ski
in a place like this
once you're at the top you have about
four thousand feet or vertical drop
until you get to the bottom
i will remember that moment for the rest
of my life
[Music]
my name is emma dalstrom i'm from sweden
and i'm a professional free skier
i'm yes presader i'm also a professional
free skier we're both on the swedish
national team
we travel all over the world to ski but
we usually go to the mountains where
it's cold and snowy when we got to peru
we started in a small oasis called
wakachina
you would look around and all you could
see is desert
[Music]
[Applause]
i was really nervous for my first round
in the sand because obviously it's not
snow
it felt sticky in the beginning but when
you got some speed it felt pretty
similar to snow actually
[Music]
it felt pretty cool to ski in shorts and
a shirt
[Applause]
we stayed there for about three days and
did some rails and jumps
and then we headed out to cerro blanco
which is basically one big mountain of
just sand
once we were at the base of cerro blanco
we hiked with all our gear for about
three or four hours
by the time we got to the top it was
completely dark
that next morning when we first saw the
view
that was magic
i watched the sun come out over the
mountains
and then we just dropped in
[Music]
it was such a crazy feeling and i was
smiling the whole way down
[Music]
you